I'm three brofist hey I like Felix how
you doing hello are you ready to wreck
people yes really bad at this from no
most is that we have fun no no you got
it all wrong all right this is about
winning or win it don't worry no I have
never ever ever won all right you're pro
I don't believe a word just don't die
I'm just gonna be I never die you don't
worry about a gonna die
the don't ha how dare you sing Felix
come on I'm not gonna die no Limpy I
have a beard beards never die I'm buying
products use doing right how do we do it
we have to win this one
I'm I don't wanna cry there's no this is
on the team I don't like this I'm gonna
poke him get him get that bench it's not
worth it
do it always is all right well what who
died who was it who was a minion to take
all my dogs oh my god I'll never forgive
oh shoot look at me I don't like this
then keep shooting Anna toes what are
you doing you forgot about your best
player though lift the foul the ball ah
ball hit me right in the face what do
you know why do something tree I thank
you yeah that's yours [ __ ] oh shut up
oh yeah that says yes show that [ __ ]
was real real Zeus are ye the don't let
hood start thanks not what did I say
yeah get the cats go cats I believe
educates 40 pi ie ya know
you'll never get a kale never even used
my cat okay even user should not have
wasted your cats go guys they're in my
flame the groomer thing I need my tree
god dammit why did I go hey this is like
oh I'm the real Zeus [ __ ]
oh ye oh god help help I want is this
deaf skull what was that but a bug okay
what is this Christmas tree doing that's
awesome my face
I'm ready cooling get here last time
I've used Oh get Zeus bit get them get
them get the cats out get the cats out
you're dying now I'm fine okay yeah oh
it's cuz thanks goodbye yes we're
waiting
this is amazing it's speed now tree guy
do something tree guy yeah yeah yeah
guys it's a close I'm gonna cry forever
if we don't win I am pushing like a
pregnant lady I swear to God I swear to
god this guy but get this guy get this
game gets good Oh
oh my god I don't believe it I don't
believe it
fine oh my god that's ready oh my god
hashtag Christmas sweater - I I gotta go
now though but it was fun finally
winning I'll never I'll never forget
great having a conversation a bit of
hard time thanks thanks for joining guys
I had a lot of fun sorry if you didn't
make it into the game
hope I can do more all right brofist on
three one two three bro friend
all right I had so much fun playing with
you bros that was just one of many games
that we did I hope I can do more games
that I I play with you bros can see
brothers are pretty cool the smite World
Championship is happening the 9th of
January but there might be a little
better than me the players there it
should be a lot cooler to watching then
then watch me scream and yell like an
idiot playing see you should check that
out also you boys can get your own
brofist logo in the game just follow the
link in the description a lot of people
have been asking for it it's pretty cool
that we get that so Alamo and yeah
that's all for now as always stay
awesome bros well that's too psyched to
sagged to Saturn okay
destroy it what okay I destroyed it
oh god it's the Nazis damnit any big box
give it their crazy
take this Nazi scam